here's one that's kind of timely that we
should you know i feel like close out on
actually i don't know
i was gonna say that woman who got hit
with the loose basketball and then now
she's like suing wait was this a nba
game mm-hmm yeah
like the basketball just like flew out
of the court and just
on the head yeah bonked her on the head
and she was like laughing when it
happened
dude that happens to like every single
eight-year-old in the world
you've never got hit on the head with a
basketball in gym class happens all the
[ __ ] time
yeah happened at a hornet's game
uh i want to see that clip
uh here it is red marks on her face and
just today her doctor told her not to
return to her finance job for the next
three weeks i probably did not expect to
be part of the action it's not just the
injuries that upset isabella
and there definitely was allowed it
froze i didn't see it
isabella also takes issue with what the
player posted after the game he put the
watching emoji and says happens to the
best of us was that appropriate
no
by no means was that appropriate oh come
on
oh
oh she got nailed offering isabel
that's a really nice [ __ ] offer
courtside tickets for getting hit in the
head with a ball i know man which by the
way is a risk that you [ __ ] take by
going to an nba game yeah i would have
taken the courtside tickets
what are you suing for
i mean there's so many ways to milk 15
seconds of fame like in that scenario if
you take it in stride if you like give
me more you know like you amp it up
who knows bro you could like you could
transform that into being like the ball
in the face girl
at the game so maybe maybe the stadium
wants you there for more than one more
court side
you know because then it's like oh
you're the you're the ball to the face
girl so you could be like the next
island boys basically yourself yeah kind
of like that could be anyone at any time
it doesn't matter what happens to you or
who you are
you know if you milk something well
enough
then you could be famous
yeah like i think there's a
a way to play that you know and uh
you take the first set of courtside
tickets you got a t-shirt i'm the girl
that took the ball to the face
everyone's like oh my god innuendo
and then ratings go up and then the
stadium's like dude we need you at every
game like you're you're making the fans
go crazy
and then you know you change your
instagram handle to ball to the face
girl yeah
you don't sue
and every game
they hit you with a ball
i mean every game at halftime they're
like all right it's time for ball in the
face girl
and she's sitting there like
and someone just
[Music]
launches a basketball
yeah
it's the new half court shot bro yeah if
no it's like you get one shot and if you
can hit her
you get courtside tickets
but if you miss she gets courtside
tickets yeah well no she's there at
every game now because she's the best
she's paying payroll yeah yeah
see that could be you but you don't sue
yeah
ah sue you just uh you don't make the
party fun anymore yeah
come on yeah